this one time on tour
okay oh that's a tough one this one time
on tour i was with charlie murphy we'll
go back to that
and uh
this kid at the tempe improv
was also into martial arts
and thought that his style was superior
to charlie's and charlie said that it
wasn't
and they had a little kung fu match
in in the
in the right right you know the
black and white tiles and i remember
charlie was twisting up so bad he wasn't
even looking at the guy he was just
looking over at me and smiling the whole
time he was doing it
and he just i just remember somebody had
turned the kid around
where he was behind him and his arms
were all up in his face and charlie was
just laughing
and charlie had this laugh
so the kid was
humiliated i remember i wanted to laugh
but i was just like well i don't know
karate either so even though that kid's
losing
charlie he'll kick my ass